Speaker 1: All right, this you are not going
to believe, I would say, unless you've been
following politics in the United States, in
which case you won't even find it surprising
so-called pro-life Republicans, self-described
pro-life Republicans are now debating
whether women who have abortions should
be killed. Really supportive of life,
aren't they? This is happening in Texas, this is
happening within the Republican Party, in Texas,
in suburban Fort Worth, House runoff Republicans
debate killing women over abortion The best way to
create and foster a community that supports
life is to kill women who had abortions whites
should Texas punish abortions by putting teenage
girls and women to death or not? Writes Yahoo
News. That's the current debate of the Republican
Party of Texas, where outlawing abortion is no
longer a question of if or when, but a question
of whether to kill women for getting one.
Listen to this. They want us to believe they are
pro-life, North Richland Hills Republican David
Lowe swears his campaign in the May 24 runoff
election has nothing to do with killing women.
I'm not even a fan of the death penalty, he said.
But then he went on to praise a House bill that
would have made ending a pregnancy a potential
capital crime. Now, understand that in Texas,
capital crimes can be punishable by the
death penalty. You have an abortion,
you're charged with a capital crime.
You could be given the death penalty
for that capital crime. Do we all agree abortion
is murder? He asked the crowd. Absolutely. There
should be consequences for it. Of all the
opponents, Low, an Afghanistan war veteran,
chose to run against District
91 state Rep. Stephanie Klick.
Click a 35 year nurse has been a low key House
leader in Texas, is one step at a time effort
to end abortion. Texas has reduced remember legal
abortions by about 10 percent. Abolishing abortion
is important, but we can do that without giving
women the death penalty. The death penalty they
are debating in Texas. Should women be killed
if they have an abortion? You may remember
that another Texas Republican lawmaker is
attempting to make abortion punishable by
the death penalty, as reported a few weeks ago
by the Texas Tribune. This legislation was filed
about three weeks ago by state Rep. Brian Slayton.
It does not include exceptions for rape or incest.
It does exempt ectopic pregnancies that threaten
the life of the woman. But this is a bill that
would abolish and criminalize abortions, and it
would leave both the women and the physicians who
performed the procedure to face criminal charges
that could carry the death penalty. Therefore,
life guys. And so if a woman has an abortion,
you kill the woman and you kill the doctor.
Think about that now, Donald Trump, you may
remember, kind of stepped into this the INEC's
Trump was pro-choice his whole life. Trump was
pro-choice 68 years. Then he became a Republican
and ran for president. So of course he had to
say I had an epiphany, I had an awakening and now
I'm against abortion. But Trump didn't know
the anti-abortion talking points. So when being
interviewed by Chris Matthews in 2016, Trump
was asked Should there be a punishment for
the women? And he said, yes. Remember this?
Speaker 4: Do you believe? Do you believe
in punishment for abortion? Yes or no as a
principle? The answer is that it has to be
some form of punishment for the woman. Yeah, it
has to be some form of fine or imprisonment for
a young woman who finds herself pregnant
after being determined. Wow. Do you know
Speaker 1: the next day Trump had to walk that
back because the Republicans explained to him,
No, no, no, no, no. We're against abortion, but we
don't say punish the woman. That's too far for us
in 2016. Now in Texas, it's a serious
debate. Absolutely horrifying stuff.